but the economics of Bitcoin thank you
for the introduction and so it's nice to
be here
I'm gonna talk about Bitcoin
particularly looking at it through
through an economic lens now you know
there's been a lot of media attention
around Bitcoin and blockchain and crypto
currencies more more broadly I'm gonna
be focusing on a particular aspect of
this space in particular when you know
you read about Bitcoin in the press it's
often viewed as kind of a speculative
asset and what's the price and so on and
so forth I'm not going to be talking
about that or those kind of economic
aspects at all I'm gonna be viewing a
Bitcoin through the lens of what it
actually does in that it maintains a
distributed ledger and functions as a
payment system right so the the
fundamental idea of the blockchain as
its applied in in in Bitcoin another so
called a public permissionless type of
systems is it's a it's a way to maintain
distributed consensus about a kind of
ledger ie you know sort of a bank
balances and it's also a way to transfer
you know money from from from one
account to another
ie a a payment system so in order to
think about Bitcoin as a payment system
I think it's helpful to kind of contrast
that with with traditional payment
system systems like PayPal venmo maybe a
Fed wire or swift internationally these
are what I'll call centralized payment
systems you have the users at the bottom
and they're all interacting with let's
say one corporation or one entity that
that sort of provides the service right
that you know so you know it could be
run by a consortium like Swift or
Fedwire could be an individual company
there's there's Network effects here in
terms of payment systems the more people
use it the more useful it is so
oftentimes these are also monopolies
they're natural monopolies and often
times you know they may need to be to be
regulated to contrast with that you know
Bitcoin is is a two-sided platform you
know again you have the users on the
bottom people who are maintaining
balances and transferring funds between
each other on the other side you have
the server
providers these are the so-called miners
these are the people who are validating
those transactions and making sure that
you know when you spend money that you
actually have it and you haven't spent
it before and so on and so forth so in
some sense it's a two-sided platform
like you know lyft or uber or Airbnb but
another sense it's also different in
that there's not an organization or
entity modulating the activity in the
middle it's purely done by protocol by a
set of mechanical rules so you know
again we look at centralized monopoly
type of solutions there's a set of rules
governing how payments work and so on
that's a set by the other monopolist how
much infrastructure should be provided
to provide reliable service and security
and so on again determined by the firm
or organization typically the prices are
set you know on PayPal charges a certain
fee if you want to use their service you
you you pay that otherwise you don't and
ultimately what's the trucks mechanism
when I when I use PayPal to sort of uh
you know send money how can I ultimately
be sure they're not going to walk away
with my money well ultimately I have
legal recourse right at the end of the
day you know I could I could sue them if
if if they walk up with that money to
contrast with Bitcoin the rules are
intermediated by the protocol in the
middle but on all the rest of this is an
equilibrium outcome right and that's
kind of amazing right so it's it's sort
of amazing that it's uh it's possible
that it functions and that you know
truly sort of high value balances are
maintained and exchanged in the system
and it's it's really kind of a novel
economic structure that I'm not sure has
been has been seen before especially
this aspect of trust without any sort of
rule of law kind of thing and um the
purpose of this talk is to sort of try
and understand the novel economic
structure and and and understand these
these these equilibrium outcomes that
that that either that occur here
so just in the interest of time I'm not
going to go over related literature what
I'm going to spend the balance of my
time talking about I'm going to take a
high-level perspective of just what the
blockchain is and how Bitcoin works I'm
going to try and give just enough
details in terms of understanding a
Bitcoin and its implementation of the
blockchain from the perspective of a
two-sided platform I'm going to present
an economic model which which seeks to
to analyze that where we have nice
analytic solutions and we compare with
empirical data and there's gonna be a
whole bunch of implications mainly this
this this whole amazing thing that I
spoke of that's you know it's even
credible that it's kind of a possible to
build up this trustless system it's it's
it's built on it has some significant
downsides and and one of those is that
delays are very important right we're
gonna see that for the you know well
functioning from a from a revenue
perspective of Bitcoin it's important
that there be congestion and in the
attendant delays and and finally there's
gonna be some kind of protocol
implications so when thinking about
designing these kind of systems rather
than you know the sort of Bitcoin design
where you have infrequent but large
blocks it's going to be much better from
an economic perspective how frequent but
uh but small blocks so time for meeting
I'll get into that so that's the that's
the plan just sort of to start with a
high-level introduction to of Bitcoin
the starting point of Bitcoin is a
transaction this is a I'm what what a
Bitcoin transaction looks like there's
some cryptographic addresses in here and
so on but a high-level there's an input
which is sort of the the account that's
paying the money so account X wants to
pay nine point five bitcoins it's going
to go out three Bitcoin to account Y
sixteen point four to account Z so
that's a nineteen point for bitcoins the
remaining point one Bitcoin is going to
be a transaction fee so what kind of
come back to that but you know putting
aside all day on the the systems
elements and cryptographic elements and
so on you know at its core a Bitcoin is
a transaction is a transfer between
balances so what is the BOK chain it is
essentially a a list of
all of these vetted past transactions
organized into blocks and organized as a
linked list back to the beginning of
time for the beginning of Bitcoin I
should say the so-called Genesis block
and so this is all transactions from the
beginning of Bitcoin and the idea is I
happen to have access to this full
blockchain this is sufficient state to
verify account balances namely if some
you know Balaji wants to pay me a
Bitcoin and I want to check does he own
a Bitcoin I can simply go back to the
origin of time and trace the activity in
his account and see if there is a
Bitcoin that has arrived there that
hasn't been spent so far so this might
be an inefficient representation but
never the nevertheless it's a it's a
representation of sufficient state to
verify account balances and the way that
Bitcoin works is you have these these
infrastructure service providers called
miners and each maintains an independent
copy of this sub blockchain hence each
miner is able to verify account balances
and to verify a transactions so those
are all the past transactions there is a
collection of new transactions
transactions that people want to affect
but that haven't been incorporated into
the blockchain yet these are sent to all
miners and maybe they hang out in
something called a mem pool so these are
transactions that haven't been confirmed
yet every once in a while ten minutes on
average a random miner is selected at a
miner selected at random that miner
assembles a bunch of these transactions
into a a block and adds them to the
blockchain and then that block is is
transmitted to others now when the
others receive them that block they also
sort of double check it and make sure
that those transactions are valid that
there's no double spending so on and so
forth
so key here which we'll get back to is
is the fact that these appear once every
ten minutes
independent of everything else that's
going on and also that they're limited
in size so each block is limited to be a
megabyte which works out to about 2,000
transactions
so why do why do the miner is a bother
right why what's the incentive to
participating as an infrastructure to UM
provider while you get paid right you
get paid in two ways if you are elected
as the the miner that's going to
generate the next block you get a fixed
amount of a newly minted coins and also
whatever transaction fees are in the
transactions in the block you get to
keep those as well right so there's two
sources of compensation right now this
is probably about 70 to 80 percent of
the compensation I'm the minting
probably about twenty to thirty percent
is a transaction fees but these are you
know so there's a having scheduled
distance set to go away over time the
vision is in the long term that the
transaction fees will provide that a
compensation to the infrastructure
providers right but for in any event
there's this to now and you know I
talked about sort of a random election
actually it's it's sort of a tournament
based mechanism this is where you hear
about proof of stake and I'm sorry proof
of work and so on I'm not going to sort
of get into the details of that from our
perspective the only thing that's going
to be important is that it requires
costly effort on the part of the miner
to sort of participate in this
tournament and that actually you know I
said a block comes out on average every
every ten minutes a Poisson
approximation with a mean and arrival
time of ten minutes is that's that's
actually really really accurate well so
the the the the tournament that's being
played is calibrated looking over the
past like you know a few weeks so that
the difficulty of that tournament is
such that you know someone can complete
it on average every ten minutes so it
sort of casts as hardware it gets better
the game that people are playing gets
harder
okay so um why does this all work well
the the Spirit is that if the miners are
small if none of them have a lot of
power of the equilibrium for them is to
do what they're supposed to do and
validate transactions and accept other
people's transactions right in
particular you know the event of getting
elected as the minor so it's going to
commit the Lex block is is very rare and
the the awards are very large right
there's visible enormous awards so if
for example a minor allows transactions
that are not valid right other miners
will sort of detect that and we'll
disregard that block and the minor will
lose steam newly minted coins and all
the transaction fees and so on right so
the idea so long as there are a lot of
miners and each doesn't have a very much
market power the the miner who selected
to produce a block has enormous
incentive to have other people accept
that block because that block involves
them accumulating some wealth and so
hence you know a miners will follow the
rules right they will only allow valid
transactions they all verify and accept
other people's block so-called you know
follow the longest chain and you know so
on so again under some assumptions that
the miners are small what are some
high-level properties here so the users
are picking the transaction fees again
this is a little bit different than
something like PayPal or venmo they're
the the platform is setting transaction
fees here are the users decide what to
pay the miners are price takers because
we're assuming that they're each
individually small they can't affect
user behavior or block transactions or
anything like that free entry and exit
of miners right so you know you don't
need any any kind of a special
permission and so on
I think the infrastructure level the
number of miners the amount of effort
spent toward mining that can be viewed
as a proxy for security because of the
idea that you have to sort of control a
non-trivial percentage of this mining
capacity to sort of cheat so the more
miners there are the more you know the
higher the the security of the system is
in some sense and again getting back to
a point I made earlier the system's
throughput doesn't depend on the number
of miners right so the difficulty of the
the the tournament is calibrated so that
blocks are produced on average every ten
minutes
you know the protocol limits the block
size to be about two thousand
transactions okay so what's our
simplified economic model here we
imagine a whole bunch of small miners
with you know some kind of a mining
capacity blocks or mind that a process
on process of raping you I've already
argued that that's a pretty good
approximation up to up to K transactions
per block users also arrive with
transactions to process the arrival rate
is going to be less than the aggregate
service rate so that the system is a
stable
each user selects a transaction fee and
each user has a different time value of
money ie heterogeneous kind of a delay
cost right so we're gonna try and
understand how this platform works from
the perspective of both the miners and
the in the users so we're gonna make
some assumptions here I'm not going to
go into them and too much in the detail
time I'm going to assume that nobody
bulks that everybody goes through the
the service business can be relaxed I'm
going to assume that no coins are minted
you know again the long-term vision is
that transaction costs are the only
compensation but in any event it
wouldn't be so so difficult to add
minting to our model so that's sort of
without loss of generality and I'm also
going to assume that again there are so
many miners that in the no individual
miner has market power is there a
question actually the case that these
are chosen yes yes
okay so the from them from the miners
perspective of the miners things are
actually I'm pretty easy so an
equilibrium an active miner well if
they're elected to produce the next
block what are they going to do they're
gonna process the K transactions with
with the highest transaction fees right
so if there's a whole bunch of
transactions waiting to be processed
let's say more than K they have
incentive to pick the K with the highest
transaction fees because they obviously
want to maximize their are their wealth
and we're assuming again that the
individual miners are small so they
can't do things like threaten you know
not to process transactions unless
there's a minimal fee or you know so on
and so forth right so that's the
behavior of the miners the total
payments of the miners is going to be
equal to the the the total transaction
fees and since there's free exit entry
and exit there should basically be a
zero profit condition ie if if there n
miners and revenue is the the amount of
transaction cost revenue my chances of
being elected is you know action one
over N so the number of miners should be
such that this is equal to the cost of
an individual mining and that's that's
given by that condition yes the miners
can enter an exit but what I'm assuming
is if you show up to make a payment and
let's say it's going to be very
expensive to make that payment you don't
say okay I'm not going to use the system
you you as someone who wants to make a
transaction and again that can be
relaxed it just makes makes some of the
formulas more complicated okay so and
this is what the mine actually looks
like if you're a if you're curious
alright so the user side is actually a
much more much more interesting what we
can already kind of see from the fact
that the miners are incentive to work
with the highest transaction fee
transactions is that basically this is
going to be a congestion queuing game
where the transaction fees are basically
bids for priority right and so blocks
are a mined and added I mean independent
of the number of miners we're gonna look
for an equilibrium where let's say a
user with type C I again that's the the
the delay cost will choose the the bid
to maximum
their utility which is given here and so
this is this is the value of the service
which is assuming it's pretty high this
is how much they're paying and this is
there waiting cost which depends on what
other people bid and again you know
analogous to earlier work that's being
done in with these kind of priority
queues you can basically work out that
the the amount of time you wait is
basically the fraction of people who are
higher type than you in the sense that
they're more sensitive for for 4/4 time
right so this is sort of a relatively
standard then you can you know you get
explicit expressions for the for the for
the waiting times and so on this is a
little bit more complicated than what
you might be used to let's say for
something like an mm1 queue and that's
because you have this batch service of a
block size k but nevertheless you can
sort of figure out everything
analytically and in equilibrium you get
an outcome as such users with higher on
delay cost pay a higher transaction fees
and the transaction fee paid by the user
which is given by this expression this
is actually equal to the externality
that they're imposing on other lower
priority users in terms of increasing
their delay right so this is actually a
VCG mechanism people are paying the the
delay cost externality that they incur
on on others right so um I'll just pause
for a second here and and and highlight
them maybe some differences to a
monopoly setting and a monopoly setting
um transactions are excluded a minimal
fee is set it and and if you're not
willing to pay that fee you know those
users are excluded and surplus is lost
here you know you generate revenue
without excluding anybody but the
flipside is in order to convince people
to pay you have to threaten them with
congestion right so we'd like to see how
that works overall we can come up with
excel ative li closed-form expressions
for the delay costs incurred in
equilibrium and the revenue it depends
on the the distribution of the types of
a level of overall congestion in terms
of sort of the other system load and the
block size the formulas are there but
but but the amazing thing is actually it
really matches the other the data well
right so here on the transaction fee
side we can observe what that
historically here I have a data set
which is about six years of data for
Bitcoin each point is a day on the
x-axis is the average block size for
that day and remember that the maximum
block size is a megabyte so the average
block size on a day that's a proxy for
the system load for how congested it is
it's going to be a as a fraction of the
megabyte a number between 0 and 1 on the
the y-axis is the total transaction fee
revenue for a block and you can see that
you know the black curve is a model
calibrated with one parameter and the
the dots are the actual data I'll make a
couple of observations the first is
unless you have reasonably high load
like 70 80 80 percent there's basically
no revenue generated by this mechanism
you need significant delay to start to
generate revenue once you do get to the
70 or 80 percent you do start to
generate revenue in fact it can be
significant but it also becomes wildly
unstable right small variations in the
arrival rate of customers result in big
shifts in the the amount of revenue
that's generated right so you know you
know users will pay transaction fees
force a faster service but this is only
relevant if the system is congested and
they're actually delays I'm not sure
I'll have time in to get into this
because it will be exacerbated by a by a
large block size and our models kind of
quantifies this and illustrates that
actually you need significant
utilization before before any kinds of
fees or or generated and and the
contrapositive of that is important also
if there aren't significant delays there
will be no revenues right so this
illustrates a potential sort of a you
know pitfall for the system there's kind
of two outcomes right the system could
be popular and congested in which case
there will be a lot of transaction fees
a lot of miners there will be a good
amount of security maybe even too much
right who knows if the the right amount
is being spent on security on the other
hand if people start to view the system
as maybe too congested maybe they sort
of stopped using it the congestion level
goes down miners are paid less miners
start quitting the system starts
becoming less secure and um people start
leaving in the system collapses right
and so
there's important implications when
people talk about scaling maybe then the
number one issue within the technical
community is around Bitcoin is how to
make it process more transactions per
second because it's perceived to be slow
in you know congested for example here's
here's something from January there's a
conference of Bitcoin enthusiasts in
Miami and they stopped accepting Bitcoin
as a payment right why because it's too
expensive and there's too much
congestion and I would argue that that's
not a bug that's a feature right the
alternative is if you don't have any
congestion there will be no transaction
fee payments and the system won't be
self-sustaining in in the long term yes
and the miners are needed for the
transaction and it's the fact that more
miners ensure security your said so the
the number of transactions is not proxy
for how much value is in the system
right so you can have a system where
there's a lot of value being stored in
these Ledger's but with few transactions
right and then someone could come in
with a small number of miners and take
over it and sort of take you know steal
people's money so you get paid for
mining via two mechanisms right so
you're saying the the it's ignoring
minting so good so I'm taking the
long-term view of ignoring the the
minted transactions you and and you know
for for Bitcoin for aetherium that's
what those developers say is that we
want a sort of a finite supply of coins
in the long run there will be only be
transaction fees there might be an
alternative model where you always mint
right and maybe this sort of argues for
that but that has different implications
and the fact of sort of being
inflationary if you always meant it
would it would change change the
conclusions
all right just to sort of wrap up I'll
make them one one sort of final
observation in terms of the system
parameters there are if you think about
what's generating the congestion here
what's generating the load there the
arrivals which you know those are
customers you don't control that on the
other hand there's how frequently
brought blocks are generated the block
rate and and the block size and the and
these are two things that are in the the
control of at least iya the protocol
designer right so so a natural kind of
question is you know how should how
should these be these to be decided and
I'm not going to go into the details but
there is a asymptotic limit where we
take a very large we're basically your
revenue and your delay costs scale
separately at a fixed level of load with
the with the number of with the size of
the the block and and the implication of
that is as follows each of these curves
on the x axis I have the revenue on the
y axis I have the delay cost and I'm
looking at kind of an efficient frontier
of with a particular block size as I
vary the the block rate how much revenue
would I generate and the large block
asymptotics say that these are all kind
of scaled versions of each other right
that was the the corollary that I
quickly went through and so you can see
kind of here if my goal is to let's say
generate $2,000 a block if I want to do
that with a block size of 20 well
there's going to be a certain delay cost
here if I want to do that with a block
size of 200 it's going to be a hundred
times more in terms of the delays I need
to impose on people in order to generate
the same amount of revenue and that kind
of makes sense because if you think of
situations where you have sort of very
large blocks the incentives that are
generated are to compete to be the case
person right so if K is very large you
might have someone who has enormous time
value of money but it's not going to bid
very much because they only need to be
in mm or 20,000 position and hence they
have to face an enormous amount of delay
before they start the ponying up so our
conclusion here is that people should
consider a much smaller block sizes more
broadly I think this kind of idea of a
blockchain it's kind of a amazing that
it's possible but I'm a major down sign
of at least the current sort of
implement
patience in terms of Bitcoin and
aetherium or so on is that the
transaction fees really rely on on
congestion and not even just a little of
congestion but you really need a lot of
congestion in order to generate revenue
and this will generate the kind of delay
costs so I think from at least from an
academic perspective a really kind of
interesting question is to sort of think
about what other revenue generating
rules might there be because it feels
like here while you don't have sort of
the monopolist extracting rat you have
to impose these sort of artificial
delays and there's there's an attendant
social cost so there's people have
proposals for kind of sharding right in
terms of not so much segregating the
miners but well segregating the other
users right segregating the the the bank
accounts if you will and then a miner
could choose to mine on different blocks
and you could sort of a combine them so
there are proposals for that I'm
personally I'm not familiar with the
details I think the challenges would be
if you're on one shard and I'm on a
different charge how do I pay you right
we have to sort of synchronize those two
things possibly think of a bigger
picture thing is the the security in the
system is coming from many many people
sort of checking the same transaction
and at some level that's also enormous
Lee wasteful right so if we could
somehow make it so that you shard things
and then a small number of people check
each sort of shard and then those are
somehow combined maybe there also be
like big efficiency gains that way yes
sending the system because there's a
hundreds of billion dollar market cap in
the system so like people who yeah so
that's a good point so I'm you might
think especially from the perspective of
the miners right so I'm assuming the
miner is mine because it's profitable
right
maybe they'll mine even though it's not
profitable but simply because they have
huge Bitcoin balances and so that would
be outside the model but it's a good
point